Today marks
one year into Russia's full scale
invasion of Ukraine.
There's no real end in sight right now
after 12 months of intense fighting.
The Ukrainian president
Zelensky is declaring
that the war will end in 2023.
I sat down with Defense
Secretary Lloyd Austin
outside of his office
of the Pentagon yesterday for his view
on where the war stands,
how he thinks it could end
When you look at this
and you're making your assessment,
do you think this ends with negotiations
or does it end on the battlefield?
Most likely
it will end
with some sort of negotiation.
And what the Ukrainians are interested in
is getting there,
getting the Russians
out of their sovereign territory.
And I think that's probably going
to be either going in
a point where,
you know,
I'll let the Ukrainians
speak for themselves.
Also,
and I
also discussed
the threats
that are posed
by China and US's concerns
about Beijing considering
potentially providing Russia with lethal
military assistance.
Here's what he said.
We heard recently
the US revealing some intelligence.
They do believe
China is preparing to provide
potentially lethal assistance
to Russia to help them in Ukraine.
Tell us what you're seeing
We've not seen any China provide
any material assistance to Ukraine
or to Russia at this point.
China hasn't
taken it off the table for sure.
I've engaged my counterpart early on
and told him that
this this would be a very bad mistake
if if China were to do this
would further complicate things.
And you think they're preparing
to do that?
I don't I can't speak for the Chinese.
I mean, they have
tremendous capabilities and so,
again, if they were to do that,
it would be ill advised
when it comes to that.
If they
if they do take that step
and China does move to provide
lethal assistance to Russia for this.
What are the consequences going to
look like for China?
Well, you
know, of course,
there's a reputational risk in
and of course,
I'm sure China would love to enjoy
a good relationship
with all the countries in Europe.
And and and again,
if you just look at the numbers
of countries around the world
that that really think that
what Russia has done is is horrible.
I mean, adding to that,
I think China would be a very,
very ill-Advised step for China to take.
Would it significantly help
Russia, though, if they did that?
How much
how much of a blow
would that be for the Ukrainians
if Russia starts
getting that kind of assistance
from China?
Well, you know, again,
I don't want to
get into hypotheticals, but it's clear
that China has a lot of capability
in terms of munitions and weapons.
And if they they provide the
sort of,
you know, substantial support to Russia,
it prolongs the conflict with China.
Recently, the tensions have gotten worse
between the United States and China,
especially after the US
shut down that surveillance balloon.
You tried to call
your Chinese counterpart
and they didn't answer.
Yeah.
So on the day that that happened,
my office reached out his office
to schedule a call
and they did not schedule the call.
That's
not really
you've heard me say a number of times.
Kate, one that I think
it's really, really important to
to make sure that we maintain lines
of communication open.
And I think leaders
need to be able to talk to each other to
avoid misperceptions and, and
and manage crises.
And so this is really important.
And so we hope that minister way
well we'll have a change of heart
and in schedule that call
When was the last time you talked to him?
The last time that I talked to him
was a couple of months ago, so.
Well,
I mean, how concerning is that
that the secretary of defense in the US
can't get your counterpart
in China on the phone.
Again, I think there's
risk involved with that.
I think it's important
to be
It's not like
we don't have any lines of communication
open.
You just saw
Secretary Blinken
talk to his counterpart in in Munich.
And so their diplomatic lines
of communication open.
But but I think for the military, it's
really, really important that we maintain
open lines of communication.
And right now,
there's not really one between the U.S.
military and the Chinese military.
That's that's right.
But but it doesn't
mean that there won't be one.
So I think,
you know, we'll continue
to make sure that
we stress the importance of this.
And hopefully, Minister,
we will schedule that call.
He knows where to find him.
He knows where to find you
when it comes to
shooting down the balloon.
What that looks like,
there were questions
about whether President Xi knew
about exactly
where the balloon was going,
what it was doing.
Is there a disconnect, in your sense,
between the Chinese president and
his own military
That could be.
I think
the Chinese
will have to answer that question.
But but
it could very well
be that
that he was not informed of
what was going on.
When it comes to the US
response on these spy balloons.
We saw several
shut down within a matter of days.
We haven't seen any that we know of
that have been shut down
in the last several days.
Is that because we're not seeing any?
Or the United States is deciding
and changing the threshold
of what it's shooting down
and when there have been no
threats reported?
No, no,
no balloons
that have been reported to me
that we need to be concerned about.
But we'll evaluate each
each case on its own merits.
Caitlin, you know, we'll assess the
the issue.
If it's a threat,
you know, we'll deal with it.
In the case of these three balloons
that we engaged
before, they were all operating in
in airspace
that would present a hazard
to civilian air traffic.
And they had travel routes that
passed by our
are some of our sensitive sites.
And whether or not
they had the ability to collect,
you know, we don't know.
But an exercise
using an abundance of caution,
we we decided to take them back.
Is that a pretty jarring
blind spot, though, that the US had
when it came
to what we learned about the balloons
that actually happened
during the Trump
administration, that those top officials,
you know,
your predecessor said
they didn't know about?
Well, we've
we've learned a lot
over the years
as we've continued to focus
on this problem set.
And and certainly,
you know, we use that
knowledge and analyzing
what not only what happened in the past,
but what's happening now
and what could happen in the future.
And Taiwan is obviously a major
part of this.
There are reports that the U.S.
is preparing to send more U.S.
military forces to Taiwan.
Is that accurate?
I won't comment on troop deployments
or operations or our training.
What I will tell
you, Caitlin,
is we remain committed
to supporting Taiwan
in accordance
with the Taiwan Relations Act.
We're going to do everything
that we can to help them
acquire the means to defend themselves.
The general,
who's the head of Air
Mobility Command, recently
sent a memo out
saying that China in the US,
he believed, would be at war
two years from now.
He said, quote,
My gut tells me we will fight in 20, 25.
Is that true?
What you've heard me say in the past
and I'll say it again
today, is I don't see an imminent attack
by China on on Taiwan
And
what you have to
watch you know what we we
we can talk about what we see
and what we see is increased activity
by the Chinese and in the Taiwan Strait
that we've seen
a number of centerline line crossings
in the airspace.
We've seen
increased activity
in the waters around Taiwan
as China continues to try to intimidate
Taiwan.
Given that,
why do you not think
an attack is imminent,
given you're seeing
that increased activity?
There are a number of reasons that,
you know,
that I won't go into here,
but I don't think it's
and she's best interest to
to attack Taiwan at this point in time.
And you have to judge them by by by
what you're seeing.
And again,
we are seeing increased activity.
We got to make sure that we have
that we remain focused on this
and we have the ability to deter
China from from making a bad decision
and we will have that.
We have the capability now.
We will continue to have the capability.